nothing about engineering but I just was
fascinated by it and i bought a little i
think would cost me a hundred dollar
computer called a Timex Sinclair around
1981 and I began tinkering with it
learned a little bit of basic program I
just did it at home on the weekends and
at night is abby and i began to then i
bought a much more expensive computer
and around I want to say 1983 or so
something like that i bought an apple 2e
and that cost me like thousands of
dollars for the computer and the disk
drives and all that kind of stuff didn't
have a hard disk of course eventually i
bought a hard disk for it which also was
unbelievably expensive and i think what
fascinated me about it was the the
communications aspects of it which were
very crude in those days but you could i
was very early on what we used to be
called kulitan boards you know like
forums that you would see today on the
web but they were all text and they were
just local and then i got on compuserve
and then I got on AOL and almost as soon
as the internet became publicly
available i was on that so it was my
hobby and and that's how i got into it
and you know eventually I came up with
the idea to stop writing about serious
global national security kind of things
which I was doing and to start a new and
different kind of technology column
you